money I'm just going to run you through
a lot of slides
this is a bronze that is currently
missing from India and is hidden in the
heart of Manhattan and you've been
searching for it for the last three
years and I just want to show you a few
pictures how these branches are
worshiped back home in India I'm just
going to run you through a few more
slides how objects when they move
removed out of context lose their
significance this is a seventh century
cave sculpture this worshiped on site
and especially bronzes which are today
much prized by the art market we in
India look at it as bodies of garden and
they are dealt as living Souls living
gods this was a thousand year bronze and
you can still see the smile on his face
and that's how beautiful these objects
are but they were never meant to be
objects of art they were meant to be
bodies of guard sadly I come from India
where there's no conflict we've had a
stable garment but I think in terms of
cultural property and theft we would
equal some of the distinguished speakers
above me and that's a reason where I've
been trying to fight and this is
actually a sacred site it's got an
inscription that dates back to 2,300
years ago and we are meeting a team that
is showing them that sadly these
mountains are being queried for granite
and this actually talks about
two salesmen who are selling sugar and
salt 2,300 years ago these mountains
would probably go off in the next two to
three years we also had a great
tradition of honoring our fallen
including a dog and this is actually a
honorary stone praising a dog from the
7th century naming it and that's how big
a tradition that we are this is a 7th
century dog that has been immortalized
in stone for biting off a robber we have
tons of Heritage Sites in India and this
is one small temple which came to me
when I was called for this conference
not for the beauties it holds I just
want to show you the size of this
sculpture that's a cocky by the way and
this temple had a property dispute in
the 10th century and there were a couple
of rich people who are trying to clean
the temples property and the custodians
of the temple
actually came up with a simple solution
to prove that the temple land belong to
the God they gave up their lives and
that's the tradition that I come from
where God's property is valued with
their lives sadly it's been reduced to
this state we've been trafficked I'm
just going to run you through images
where the hands are sort of thinking
that there's gold in their ceiling
panels lifted in many museums we find
these objects entire panels that's the
entire set that has been taken off this
is from archaeological protected site in
India and replaced with fakes it takes a
trained eye but then you can still spot
that the third sculpture is a recent
replica we have tons of such raptors the
schita there is modern fake and where
are these originals I'm going to name a
few people because this was part of a
book Sothis was part of beta Watson's
book and sadly what happened to the
perpetrators of this crime
Vaman Gear was acquitted by a lower
court and the gamma of India has not had
even filed an appeal in the higher court
where this convicted criminal at that
point of time had confessed to selling
10,000 objects of art on industrial
scale looting with SWAT beasts and the
dealers who sacked are currently running
an antique shop as well and I just want
to mention the CAG report by the
Government of India it said from 2000 to
2012 the Archaeological Survey of India
did not even restitute back one object
and since they also mentioned there is
no archive of centrally protected sites
and since we are with the V&A I just
take a time it does mention that during
the pre British era the National Museum
loaned 700 items to the V&A for which
they have no record and technically
these items are still on loan and if we
can find a document India would ask for
it
so what's the problem
we have a large quantum of dispersed art
and then this is the archive that I'm
currently working with with the French
Institute it's still not digitized and
you're very small so every time we go
there we spend about two days going
through 6,000 objects and to come up
with objects that are currently on sale
and the prices are astronomers you've
got objects that are selling for
millions of dollars for almost three
million and the sad state of my police
force back home in India in fact this
bronze I'm not sure if you'd recognize
it it's in the US and seen in the US for
the last 40 years it was advertised
along with the concert and they
advertised the 5000 rupee reward for
anyone who gives information about its
theft last year they didn't even know
that it's left India 70 years ago and
the price was $50 we also have village
from sites like Chandra Catawba which
was excavated as late as 1967 and every
museum every collector has this era
katas with them beautiful sights not
much as even known about them in India
so we as a online group we decided to be
the change so what did we do we started
focus on restitution we started building
awareness we act as a deterrent
influence policy with the garment and
you can see there's two guys the guy in
charge of lining the road didn't have
the job of moving the tree trunk and
then we work with capacity building so
the results so this was the ordinary
shutter which was currently in Australia
we tracked it we managed to find it we
managed to find out it was a replica
that has put up there it was returned it
was it done by the Australian premier to
the Indian Premier and then this led to
a large-scale cache of stolen objects
these are robber photos of oscillations
holds them despite this proof
and a whole lot of provenance papers
which are obviously fake with the Art
Loss Register certificated a practically
useless for India and then this is the
nut Raja that came back and this is the
empty shrine that was there the robber
photos a press campaign we did a YouTube
launch for this and finally came back
and the greatest pride is not returned
but when he went back to the exact
sanctum where he was stolen from and
this was the village pre when it was
looted and when the villagers decided to
welcome back the nut Raja we have helped
with lot of these restitution efforts
and I'm happy to share my stories later
thank you